第1回場面きみかん様母と兄者数そうですたよくで大変お待たせいたしました以前も
発表いたしましたんですけども私の動画の中にたびたび出てくる場面切り替えこれで
あいぞっていうやつんですけども
もうかれこれ大分大附が使ってたんで変えようかなっていう話で海てで皆さん
場面携帯を作ってくださいというお願いをしてたくさんの応募をいただいてその中から
さらに高絞ってしまってしまって絞ってを見ねえとされて作品を今回みんなで見て行き
たいと思いますもう一度説明するは場面携帯って言うのはねそのばねぇ例えばこの部屋
から外に出るということかの間に変化を付けるために良いなら一瞬切り替えみたいな
のっている結構いろんなユーチューバーさんがっ
やってるんですけどもそれを俺が変えたいなぁと思って偉さんだから5勝した中で今回
ちょっといろいろ今から見ていくんですけども一番良かったやつを今後の動画に使用さ
せて頂きたいと思っておりますね本当にねもうね重要なポイントは結構絞られてるん
ですけども絶えず短さ
そんな場面綺麗じゃなかったりと見てるともうちょっとプラズバッ切ってするかもしれ
ないでねコンパクターば便切り替えそしてた
インパクト僕のイメージに合ってるかどうかとかその色んな奴とおり混ざってるんです
けどそれはちょっと総合的に見てて新しい場面切り替え横書き見ていきたいと
思います公募件数などは短い期間だったんですけども
sunline 503ず7件の応募がありますありがとうございますハイライトと
言いますけど個目に止まったような奴はこれから見て行きたいと思いますか
タイではさっそく見ていきましょうすっげー見るだからもうどんな面でいきますまず一
発目ですこちら
あ
たたき見た大地からめっちゃ一瞬でしたねー
ねそういうイメージなんですこれでいいと思いますねこれにいってわけじゃないんです
けどもどんどん見ていきましょう
大可愛いかわいいかめかめ所沢一瞬よぎりましたねー
を
この音楽なんかよく聞きますねめっちゃ年日生まれちゃんぽくて来なかったですね
待ってはかれこれ1審消防すぎてむずくねこれこれ
水がはもまずいぞどんどん行きましょう
すげー
一瞬でこれすごいわえーすごいですうんすごいねええ
すごい一瞬でから攻撃を持ってったな進ん年ありがとうございます次です
昔のエンディングの穴俺を使っているんですねああ
うんまたまたっ
右下のやつ始めるのが消してくれることを願ってますてくれる
powerdirector っていうソフトで作ってるんですねこれ
次ですっ
をシンプルですねすぎですはぁ
はっはっ盛大で俺は好きですってこのあとちょっと分かりやすいようにボイスと出会い
高みな感と言ってからやってみましょうかとつのマナー皆さんもイメージがしやすいと
思うんですで愛子
その描いてみようう
ごめんな follow いまー
家って言うんだよ最悪ドック破けた服や売れたんだよむくみ機にむき身キャメル長と
その服8月
あって見守っに男性のでは別に行きましょうか出会い号
今の前髪限定ジャブスリー可愛かったら今デー号
[拍手]
個性的だね絵の具感があったりでは行こう
あああーー
いいですねなんかエンディングとねちょっとあっているたまたねいい感じましたね
今のエンディング大丈夫曲を好きでした早い買おう
金腹筋したら今長い目で見ると使いなぜかもしれないですね腹筋系は
では行こう
を美術いいわーデリカ大
前髪前がに発に立ったけど今出会い買おう
a 変える東レを足して2で割ったような顔
割と綺麗じゃないも採用代行
a
すごーい詰まってるん
すごい思ってるすごいでこりゃすごいわ
ローラー
メッツいるのパウダーこの方のデートん
[音楽]
タッキーさんじゃいこーへーんじゃ行こう
ああ
かわええ目がクリッとした今は難なくこういうえおレベルと好きですね
いやー個人になる続きですね大根
あ
大かわいいなおいこれ皆さん外かわいい水ありますお礼でもっと激しいなら血しぶきが
交付機立つような激しいいうとはなんですかねエコ
あっこ au あのめっちゃ好きでしたねなんかシンプルにまとまってるけどめっちゃ
かっこいいっ
太鼓すごいちゃんとも動画にはめてくれてる
はい
永安
思いません
ああ
true ンってやつなのねー
b 案
いろんな案を出してくれればいいか
ああああああ
もうすごい
これっぽいか
ああああああ
すごいめっちょイレクターすごいうわすごい異論ないままてる動画の音奴がガーッと
なる感じですね
カッコ様へ3パターンもありがとうございます本当にねーかおお
で行こう
をイラストいいですねありがとうございますでは行こう
あーシンプルね yes ねだからそういうボって1個出しだけで俺全然良いと思い
ますありがとうございます代行
フェズ5位15位猫
彼は一瞬だなすごい動画の日様子みてくださいこれ0秒ですよどうなんだろうねな票が
いいんだろうなぁ
ちょっとな早瀬いるようなイメージもありました代行
ああ可愛い可愛い集いですこれ回ミスツインかなんだよ
あ
俺かわいいか皆さん本当ありがとうございます僕そんな
可愛くないですよゐこ
おわーすげーすげー
あなたその大変だろうにに名所でしたら雛を大変でしょうねデー婚
新法ざっ新報その新報中央新報
0号
寸法ねえ放った
[音楽]
待っておっぱぱ
ああああああ
まだまだちょうど良い日を待っていた
これおりか俺こんな顔したのかああ
圧痛という代物でますエコな押し気味悪いバックととがエンディングと合わせてやって
めっちゃいいと思いますねどうぞ
誰々誰宇宙 a オルドええええ
ef 4言う2って項をこれ
常に周りの人しなんせな品知らんけど
ちょっと好きですねこういうなんか謎な感情ですよね代行
古俣めっちゃ怖かったけどもよく一瞬ねすごいよだぞそんなわけできたからすごいたい
んだったらどうもありがとう
0号
あーなるほどねあえて一定の健保ていくタイプなんですね
いいと思ってきますね意外とこういう音が僕無機質なもの好きなんで代行
かわイラストかわいいこんな可愛くないよ稽古
あああああ
いやもうは出るスゴ度 a 飛び出ちゃってるけど素 a day 5
ああ
シンプルでいいですねー
[拍手]
i プレーン im not play
まあで備考
なんか皆さんすごいスピードが一式してくるとあってめっちゃ短い1秒ないくらいの方
がめちゃくちゃ多いですよ
かわいいきゅんじゃないかおお
ああすごい
東海オンエアではこういう中で回インパクターでもいいですね
で a
カッコようマってすごい
ねええええなんかすごいあの gt を見たいねえこう
音かられ家たちと開票するタイプですねいやーいい作戦だと思いますありがとうござい
ますでおっ
[音楽]
ボッチャめっちゃを登っちゃうミュート出てたよ
ああ
やっぱねスライムのイメージがあるんですよね結構ピースにも飲んだよっ
なるほどねこの変わる感じのカーテンからね
いいと思いますねこっ
あーあおい
別号罠解除ん
大
[音楽]
何してないでー今あぁ
普通 a 待って
ん
ない方
あー革色ゲットに乗ってる俺霊魂
見栄え変わったんだよねージャイ子パパ
これじゃねえで行こう
[音楽]
突然捕まえるっ
捕まっちゃったってはぁ
出てしまった俺は何を見せられているんだ第号
すごいメッツがいい last day 5
これぐらいシンプルでコスです代行
rp 本
独特な音楽でおっいっ
うわぁす worth を一瞬のインパクト凄いっすけどもうすぐ迷子に入るんです国
で5
[音楽]
好きでそ音楽のインパクトがやっぱ大事かもしれないですねやめっちゃ良かったらなん
か
英語
あああああ
スキーいいですねなんかラム
水ちょっとトゥット通り全部見てから決めますねぇー
和んで行こう
んでこう
もう版行く前の労働中の画面みたいで行
グルニエずヴィッツの中に10発してたんでごっ
かっこいいうわぁ杉江をさで猫
かわいい
dqn ときてしまいます私でこっ
[音楽]
俺の子一歩来なかっていますごまあすごいすごいすごいですね
あって言ってたねえっ
なにこれポケモンからハマってすんしまーこの時の動画の300円の勝つしかなかった
時に鼻た母
adobe 社の好きな葉を入れてみてください
なるほどまずは説明までございます
は
[音楽]
ブーブーエロ
n であったか
ちょ